بعد العثور على المزيد من الوثائق السريه
في منزل الرئيس الامريكي جوبايدن همم
بيسعى الجمهوريون الان لتوسيع دائره البحث
والتحقيق بطلب سجلات الزائرين لمقرات
الرئيس الخاصه من زار مقر الرئيس في
والمنطن خلال العامين الماضيين هذا ما
يريدون معرفته بل ذهب البعض كالجمهوريه
لانس جودن عن ولايه تكساس الى حد التساؤل
عما اذا كان اي مواطن غير امريكي كانت
لديه فرصه زياره بيت بيض في وقت من
الاوقات وكان قد تم تخزين الوثائق في
المنزل في منزل نائب الرئيس السابق
والرئيس الحالي لمده ست سنوات على الاقل
لكن اكثر ما صدم المسؤولين الامريكيين هو
مكان التخزين والذي كان في الواقع مراه
سيارات الرئيس على عكس ترامب الذي يواجه
ايضا قضيه مماثله عندما عثر مكتب
التحقيقات الفيدراليه على وثائق في منزله
الصيفي وافقت اداره البايضين على اطلاق
سجلات الزوار الى البيت الابيض لكنها ابقت
على هويات اولئك الذين زاروا بايد سريه في
حين سافر الرئيس اكثر من 50 مره منذ تولي
هو منصبه